[Musique]
quoi qu'il arrive la flamme de la
résistance française ne doit pas
s'éteindre et ne s'éteindra pas ces mots
prononcés par le général de gaulle le 18
juin 1940 sur l'antenne de la bbc sont
aujourd'hui entrés dans l'histoire
arrivé à londres la veille depuis
bordeaux le général de gaulle est peu
connu et surtout bien seul
in any troupes ni force politique
accompagnée seulement de son aide de
camp il choisit de continuer le combat
alors que le maréchal pétain vient
d'annoncer qu'il va demander aux
allemands la signature d'un armistice
grâce à l'appui du premier ministre
britannique winston churchill il est
autorisé à intervenir sur les ondes de
la radio britannique
c'est dans un petit appartement
londonien qui leur est dit
ratures le texte de son appel
chaque nom
aux alentours de 18 heures le 18 juin il
s'adresse à la population française dans
un studio de la bbc
son texte est court et surtout destiné
aux militaires aux ingénieurs et
ouvriers
il les invite
un logement de l'effort de guerre des
alliés à la route
à peine la seconde donc
audience face à la déroute militaire et
à la débâcle
français au talent d'autres priorités
écouter la bbc et encore moins au
général
toutefois son texte le land
l'enregistrement n'a pas non plus été
conservés il n'en reste aujourd'hui que
peu de traces hormis le manuscrit
original on confond d'ailleurs souvent
appel du 18 juin avec celui du 22 juin
dont il existe un témoignage sonore
il peut alors être mairie bras
mais goûter et à me nuire
[Musique]
malgré tout il est considéré comme
l'acte fondateur de la france libre et
de la résistance au cours de l'été 1940
quelques milliers de volontaires y
réponde et rejoignent les rangs des
forces françaises libres
la voix du général devient ensuite peu à
peu familière durant le conflit
il intervient 67 fois sur la bbc ce qui
lui vaut le surnom de général micro